[Musica]
io vorrei iniziare il mio discorso con
una domanda che vi sembrerà totalmente
fuori luogo però servirà poi per rendere
realmente tangibile insomma il senso di
quello che vi sto per dire prima stavo
in camerino no sai quando ti stai per
preparare allora mi sono vestito tutto a
puntino mi sono guardato allo specchio
detto bene sto bene
esco fuori dal camerino sul corridoio
trovo il mio ufficio stampa
ora io non sono famosissimo per per la
mia eleganza quindi già la vedo lì che
mi guarda un po spaesato quella camicia
metterà nei pantaloni va bene
hai ragione thorne in camerino mi metto
la camicia nei pantaloni mi riguarda
allo specchio tutto a posto esco di
nuovo nel corridoio
stavolta a fianco del mio ufficio stampa
ci stava il mio manager mio manager è
l'opposto dell'ufficio stampa e fatti mi
guarda la prima cosa che mi dice insomma
donna santa quella camicia nei pantaloni
dai vent'anni suo vecchio dentro
torno il camerino di nuovo alla fine mi
guarda allo specchio camicia dentro
camicia fuori non riesco a decidere è
optato per la maglietta quindi io mi
rifaccio la domanda come sono vestito
secondo voi nel senso io sono partito no
a guardarmi allo specchio la prima volta
con la camicia fuori e mi sembrava di
stare bene mi sono riguardato la seconda
volta allo specchio con la camicia
dentro è di nuovo mi sembrava di stare
bene con la t shirt e di nuovo mi
sembrava di stare bene
ora al di là del fatto che mi sembra
ovvio che ha una facciata bellezza per
questo bene con tutto il punto è come
sono vestita oggi è dietro a questa
domanda che può sembrare assurda si
nasconda un po il senso di tutta la mia
storia perché per chi ho davanti allo
specchio vedeva un'immagine di michele
che era un'immagine bidimensionale di
quella che invece è una mia visione
molto più ampia di un michele a 360
gradi quindi l'immagine dello specchio
in qualche modo perdeva di verità
assoluta perché appunto un'immagine
bidimensionale di una tridimensionalità
molto più complessa
ora
c'è c'è dietro a questo cioè appunto il
senso del mio percorso perché perché da
qui da questo io ho capito che per avere
una buona percezione di sé bisogna
creare intorno a sé una grossa
partecipazione al proprio percorso al
proprio progetto
nel mio caso poco fa era il discorso su
come mi presento oggi
questo perché perché io ho mai avrei
immaginato no
indossando la prima camicia che avrei
distrutto poi l'ipotesi della camicia
fuori l'ipotesi della camicia dentro per
arrivare ad una ipotesi totalmente nuova
inaspettata della t shirt che mi
sembrava comunque assolutamente
sufficiente per presentarmi qui allora
il punto qual è no riflettere su quello
che è il senso della bidimensionalità e
della tridimensionalità ora mi
interrompo il secondo per presentarmi
bene ma io per chi non mi conoscesse per
chi non conoscesse insomma la mia storia
io inizio a scrivere il mio curriculum a
18 anni vincendo uno dei talent show più
noti in italia che cos'è un talent show
tallinn cioè un trampolino di lancio e
come tale penso che già si possa
scoprire la sua dinamica all'interno di
questa piccola metafora che cosa succede
se un trampolino di lancio che tu
appunto di lanci verso l'alto ai questo
slancio bellissimo magari no tu se sei
allenatori e sci non è il mio caso se si
è allenato do riesce a descrivere delle
acrobazie bellissime che mettono in
risalto tutta la tua muscolatura insomma
il punto però qual è che alla fine cadde
in acqua e dipende come cade in acqua ma
puoi entrare in acqua perfettamente
compiendo un tuffo incredibile oppure
come è successo a me vai dritto proprio
così vi fa la famosa spanciata noe ti
fai male
questa è la discografia che mi hanno
presentato la prima volta a 18 anni
quando io mi sono affacciato sul mercato
musicale no ed è proprio in questo
momento che entrano in gioco non in
questo momento del mio percorso che
entrano in gioco i discografici ora per
farvi capire bene qual è il ruolo di
discografico un discografico è quella
cosa che sta tra il bagnino e
l'allenatore perchè perchè ti deve
comunque allenare no per
per resistere il più possibile in questo
slancio dal trampolino e allo stesso
tempo deve essere pronto no in qualche
modo a soccorrerli nel caso in cui come
appunto è successo a me vai giù di
spanciata e ti fai male ora quando la
discografica è venuta da me dopo questa
prima spacciata a dirmi danni che adesso
risaliamo là sopra poi ti fai male di
nuovi ho detto no detto non mi va io non
ci sto giocare con la mia vita ha detto
che non ero così pronto adesso sera un
termine un po forte però prostituire la
mia vita in questa montagna russa sulla
mia vita
a 18 anni ho detto di no detto che non
ci stavo e da qui sorge il primo
problema dei tanti che il primo problema
però che io ho bisogno di cantare a 18
anni o quella spavalderia sufficiente
per dire cavolo ma io voglio rendere
questa passione una professione e come
fai 4 per un secondo a parlare no del
discorso di bidimensionalità e
tridimensionalità di cui
accennavo all'inizio io sono un grande
estimatore no del di grandi artisti
della musica sempre ascoltato un sacco
di cose uno fra tanti adesso mi viene in
mente david bowie na david bowie è un
grandissimo artista che io ho ascoltato
insomma nel mio percorso di crescita
e allora la domanda che mi pongo è per
dire un grande come david bowie è
bidimensionale e tridimensionale
allora io da qua ho provato a darmi una
risposta no e mi dico secondo me david
bowie è tridimensionale
perché io quando ho detto david bowie
sono sicuro che tutti voi non avete
votato solo un nome
non avete evocato solo una canzone avete
vocato qualcosa di molto più grande che
ha un immaginario che è tutta una
costumistica che proprio di questo
personaggio è tutto un tappeto sonoro
che proprio proprio di questo
personaggio avete vocato tutta la sua
forza carismatica lor ed è qui che david
bowie diventa tridimensionale perché un
suo disco un suo vinile diventa la
chiave d'accesso per un mondo molto più
ampio qua mi permetto di fare una
parentesi da creativo no questo è un po
il senso della musica io perché ho
bisogno di ascoltare un artista come
david bowie come mille altri perché
evidentemente quella persona ha trovato
le parole al posto mio
perché è riuscito a descrivere con delle
parole che appunto io non sapevo
distinguere con dei suoni che non
riusciva ad intuire un mondo che anche
il mio mondo io ho bisogno di quella
cosa
e nel momento in cui tu mi dai la
possibilità di accedere ad un mondo che
mi fa stare bene in cui io trovo il mio
equilibrio anche solo per tre minuti
quella significa fare musica però al di
là di questo insomma il discorso è
proprio lì no david bowie era
tridimensionale allora sempre da
creativo io di quel problema a questo
punto non è più come esistere sul
mercato discografico ma come poter
raccontare la tridimensionalità
oggi io come posso essere
tridimensionale a 18 anni ora ne ha 22 e
da lì ho iniziato a fare tutto il
percorso mio di ricerca no dicendomi
partiamo col con la prima cosa che ti
può avvenire in mente ma allora tu hai
appunto un mito in questo caso abbiamo
citato de vivo
che cosa ha fatto david bowie per
raccontare la sua tridimensionalità
allora dici
magari lo posso fare pure io ora quando
faccio questo discorso metto un po le
mani avanti dicendo che io parlo di
strategia comunicativa quindi
l'emulazione della strategia
comunicativa non è l'imitazione
artistica sono due cose molto diverse
quindi devi voi come faceva essere
tridimensionale come comunicava questa
sua tridimensionalità lo faceva
attraverso i rischi lo faceva attraverso
l'esibizione dal vivo lo faceva
attraverso le interviste
lo faceva magari attraverso no tutte una
serie no per dire di scatti d'autori non
tutti avranno visto non per dire il
periodo di ziggy stardust il fulmine e
così via
ora oggi basterebbe questo per
raccontarsi in tre dimensioni io che qua
ho provato a darmi una risposta
la risposta è sì sì in termini di
viralità perché perché magari
un'esibizione particolarmente intensa
particolarmente sentita può creare del
dibattito può creare del del confronto
non può creare appunto il fenomeno della
viralità la risposta però a questa
domanda diventa no nel momento in cui io
parlo di solidità parlo di possibilità
di crearsi un pubblico fedele delle
persone attente al tuo ascolto ketty
garantiscano la possibilità di una
continuazione nel tuo processo creativo
e produttivo
allora di nuovo io mi chiedo come si può
essere tridimensionali oggi bisogna
tenere in considerazione che cosa un
enorme cambiamento ed estensione se
volete ma di tutti quelli che possono
essere i mezzi di comunicazione la mia
possibilità di descrivervi è aumentata
i dettagli per descrivere la mia persona
si sono intensificati in che senso ha
allora da se io vi chiedo di fare una
cosa se prendete la vostra mano così la
posata sulla tasca dei pantaloni che
cosa trovate
spero per voi il telefono perché se non
vuol dire che me l'hanno rubato m ma
perché voi avete sempre il telefono con
voi dentro alle tasche magari nelle
borse non troverete mai un televisore
accartocciato non troverete mai una
rivista che avete arrotolato in qualche
modo
il vostro telefono allora il vostro
telefono è diventato un mezzo per essere
tridimensionali perché è la chiave di
accesso per una banca di dati infinita
che viene che ci suddivide no secondo
delle leggi algoritmiche di cui non
posso parlare perché trovare non me ne
intendo però è rientrata la nostra porta
rispetto a un mondo di informazioni
rispetto al quale altrimenti non avremo
accesso allora il telefono e di quel
telefono ma potrebbe essere un computer
sto contestualizzando no al telefono
come per dire il web
quindi tutto quello che hai un nuovo
media è diventata la nostra possibilità
di affacciarsi sul mondo e quindi è da
lì che io sono ripartito detto ho
bisogno di capire questa nuova
dimensione ho bisogno di capire che cosa
succede in questo territorio dove io
posso descrivere meglio la mia
tridimensionalità ora su questo mi
interrompe un secondo per mettere di
nuovo le mani avanti non è sempre facile
il moralismo ama come i telefoni
l'interconnessione fra le persone
insomma è tutto cambiato e quindi c'è
questo facile moralismo non mio nonno mi
dice sempre era meglio quando era peggio
non è così io non sto parlando di
rapporti interpersonali in questo senso
io sto parlando del mio modo di poter
comunicare una professione quindi prendo
la distanza rispetto a tutta una
dissertazione sociologica che potrebbe
asciugarci no per ore ed è appunto il
mio modo di poter comunicare una
professione io inorridisco ogni volta
quando si parla di hama quanti follower
c'hai quanti like fai perché perché
parlare di follower parlare di lai che
significa dare per assodato una verità è
un po come se io stessi raccontando il
mio lavoro creativo ad una macchina ad
un telefono ad un computer ed è come se
quel computer quella macchina e quel
telefono gratificasse rowe in maniera
diretta il mio lavoro non è così io sto
raccontando la mia creatività attraverso
il computer ad un'altra persona
attraverso un telefono ad un'altra
persona quindi dietro a quei numeri c'è
sempre un entità specifica il telefono
la macchina il computer sono soltanto un
mezzo
soltanto una piattaforma di incontro che
ci permette di creare quel tipo di
dialogo li chiusa questa parentesi io
appunto ho iniziato a indagare che cosa
poteva essere il web come poter essere
tridimensionali su sul web ed equa che
viene mossa la prima critica no che
tuttora un po serpeggia sempre quando si
parla insomma del del mio percorso e
questa critica quale è riferito al fatto
ma ma non ti senti un pagliaccio non ti
vergogni a raccontare no tutto questo di
non ti toglie credibilità notai e
credibilità alla tua creatività questo
tipo di esposizione
io per rispondere a questa critica
faccio sempre questo esempio nome non è
mai successo di scrivere io sono anche
un autore non ha mai successo di
scrivere una canzone davanti alla luna
piena
non mi è successo per dire l'ultimo
disco succedeva magari io stavo lavando
i piatti skira non è solo un ottimo uomo
di casa stava lavando i piatti stavo
stirando e ti veniva cari l'idea di un
testo di una melodia di una canzone
e allora lite la punta via dal piano
piano nasceva la canzone allora il punto
quale io nel disco racconto la canzone
su tutto il mio percorso web su tutti i
miei profili
io invece racconto il momento in cui
stavo lavando i piatti il momento in cui
stavo stirando ed è un modo per
infittire per rendere ancora più
dettagliata la trama della mia
tridimensionalità
ed è questo il punto no io a un percorso
un po contrario rispetto a quella che
alla norma perché io parto dalla
televisione e arrivo dal web
quando normalmente dovrebbe essere il
contrario questo perché perché mi sono
accorto che con i vecchi media che
appunto può essere un televisore può
essere un giornale tu hai una
comunicazione che è una comunicazione
verticale
se tu guardi la televisione sta
assistendo ad un monologo io sono
passivo rispetto al contenuto che sto
vedendo nel momento in cui io pubblico
un tweet di 140 caratteri nel momento in
cui ho pubblico un video sulla mia
pagina di facebook allora a quel punto
sto comunicando in maniera orizzontale
sto creando un dialogo sto creando una
discussione devo essere pronto a capire
che cosa sta succedendo nella community
che stai creando no io parlo sempre di
viaggio in costruzione
parlo sempre di credo molto in questa
idea di costruirsi piano piano e ci
vuole tempo per farlo ci vuole tanto
tempo e attraverso questa comunicazione
che una comunicazione orizzontale che mi
permette di affrontare direttamente chi
poi ha il piacere di comprare un mio
disco al piacere di venire ad un mio
concerto imparato ad ascoltare chi poi
ne avrebbe ascoltato ecco io attraverso
questa comunicazione sono riuscito nel
mio piccolo e poi me la tiro un po se
volete anche con arroganza a riscrivere
le leggi della discografia perché perché
mio ultimo disco ha richiesto tre anni e
mezzo di lavorazione dai 18 anni ai 22
anni e questo per i canoni standard
della discografia di oggi ha
praticamente un tempo impensabile perché
nessuno ti dedica tanto tempo questo
tempo lo trovi nel momento in cui tu
racconti questa coltivazione racconti
questo percorso e chiamiate una serie di
persone che hanno voglia di partecipare
a questo viaggio in costruzione allora
il punto qual è come essere
tridimensionali oggi imparare ad
ascoltare chi ti ascolta è un motivo per
creare questa tridimensionalità e
scoprire l'autenticità della propria
storia è un motore o po come se fosse un
ufficio marketing no tu diventi
l'ufficio marketing di te stesso la
possibilità di farti conoscere no è come
se fosse un continuo abbraccio rispetto
a chi la pensa come te a chi come te ha
voglia di compiere questo viaggio in
costruzione allora il punto è proprio
questo la tridimensionalità la klein è
al momento in cui rispetto a tutte le
possibilità di comunicarti di
descriverti tu riesci in qualche modo ad
aggiungere pixel a quella che è
l'immagine di un progetto molto più
grande nel mio caso della dimensione
musicale grazie
grazie mille